le japon a un nouveau premier ministre
shinzo abe 52 ans considéré comme un
faucon en raison de ses prises de
position en faveur de sanctions contre
la corée du nord l'une de ses priorités
sera de renouer les contacts politiques
avec la chine rompus pendant la
mandature de son prédécesseur junichiro
koizumi
reggie smith paul
il est le plus jeune premier ministre
qui est connue le japon depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale shinzo abe 52
ans était facilement élu ce matin la
tête du gouvernement par le parlement
shinzo abe appartient à une grande
famille son grand père fut premier
ministre avant d'être détenue comme
criminel de guerre par les américains et
son père ministre des affaires
étrangères député depuis 1993
shinzo abe n'était entré au gouvernement
qu en octobre 2005 avant de devenir le
successeur désigné du flamboyant qu il
ou réputé pour son allure élégante
le nouveau premier ministre est aussi un
fervent adepte du retour aux valeurs
traditionnelles du japon
un beau pays est un pays qui accordent
de la valeur à ses traditions à sa
culture à sa nature et à son histoire
est un pays qui respecte la discipline
et conserve son énergie pour construire
l'avenir et jouer un rôle de leader dans
le monde pour gagner la confiance et
l'amour des autres
partisans d'un renforcement de
l'alliance avec les états unis shinzo
abe voudrait aussi réviser la
constitution japonaise pour lui
permettre d'engager plus facilement des
troupes à l'étranger comme ici en irak
le chef du gouvernement ne cache pas non
plus son souhait d'obtenir un siège de
membre permanent au conseil de sécurité
des nations unies
des ambitions qui inquiète déjà ses
voisins la chine et la corée du sud coup
de théâtre japonais même si l'année fut
très difficile pour shinzo abe en
démissionnant le premier ministre a créé
la surprise une décision qui intervient
après une année seulement deux mandats
une année marquée par des scandales et
un désaveu électoral pour le plus jeune
premier ministre que le japon ait connu
depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale mona hintermann
à tokyo la chute du gouvernement n'a
surpris personne les japonais ont suivi
la crise politique thomas feuilleton
depuis un an les scandales les affaires
de corruption ont fini par ruiner toute
confiance le premier ministre shinzo abe
avait pourtant les larmes aux yeux en
annonçant sa démission
claude est la situation inextricable
dans laquelle je me trouve
comme ils n'ont rend ma tâche très ardue
j'en ai donc conclu que je devais
prendre une décision afin de limiter au
maximum la crise politique
ces dernières semaines la cote de
popularité du gouvernement s'étaient
effondrés et en juillet son parti avait
connu de véritable déroute aux
législatives
[Applaudissements]
il m'a déçu si ministre était corrompu
ça devait se terminer comme ça la chute
son successeur sera désigné la semaine
prochaine ce sera probablement comme lui
un conservateur un homme du parti
démocrate il n'empêche les débats au
parlement vont se focaliser sur les
questions de sécurité le terrorisme le
gouvernement sortant étaient pour le
maintien de sa présence militaire en
afghanistan
l'opposition de centre gauche elle le
refuse à toronto seront excusés
justement sur la législation
antiterroriste l'abondance qui m'a
justement comme sur la question
de nos troupes à l'étranger
nous maintenons notre position aux gens
non la bourse 2e place mondiale a frémi
-0 5% sur l' indice nikkei les hommes
d'affaires demande maintenant aux futurs
dirigeants d'entreprendre très vite des
réformes économiques le gouvernement
sortant les avait négligé
[Musique]